welcome to this video playing
international master JW okay who is this
guy
you huh mr. Beck I've played him once it
seems and here one drawn ok I'm going
for this b5 line
against NIDA 3G 3 it's not a bad line at
all it looks a bit funny but it's not
bad
I've played my fair share of 93g three
games and this is really a decent line
for black you gained some quick space on
the queenside hmm okay you can play with
d5 as well but I don't mind this kind of
this kind of structure now just get
pieces out yeah to see you want to play
you high hmm maybe maybe he plays your
fire I don't know a5 is not necessarily
it's not necessary maybe but kind of
fields fields okay oh wow it really
wants to go out for maybe I can just
persuade him not to do that nice to go
back now I guess now maybe Knight H to
f3 and Bishop f6 that might make some
sense I met the Queen G form
queen g4 could be an idea to continue
and not just retreat okay it's giving up
this pawn came
you will probably would have some kind
of compensation there huh but okay it's
kind of weird not to take it now after
this after 98 and then not taking it as
a would be very strange yeah this is an
interesting idea I was thinking if I
take if I take on e5 I could sacrifice
the queen there for an interesting play
I'm going to do that I think this is
interesting 95 I think it's too
interesting not to trim' I was thinking
Queen e5 actually if I take with the
pawn rook takes EF at like to get his
his his dark squared Bishop so the only
reason why this is not really yeah
really
clearly okay for black is the knight
only aid this night would be better I
think I would have had I would have
clearly a decent compensation here I'm
not completely completely sure about it
he wants to do deform yeah maybe yeah
I'm a knight my night my knight if I go
Knight to c6 he will play e5 it's the a
way to persuade him not to play before
maybe rook c8 takes Queen takes Queen
zai Quincy to still still probably is
something I wait I can maybe play d4 97
this could be an idea I am no he's
swinging over there okay I want the
night to want a knight on d4 how that
sets the idea and now if five he can
play he can play them push up to age
three
I don't know maybe if I would have been
a nice outpost for the night
but I'm not sure okay let's get this 2e6
to f4 that's the next step I'm going to
play Bishop see a GM I guess rook f6
maybe but Stella came and it's not I was
at that that was not what I wanted to
see but okay it's not not a big problem
I have g5 as well I have two pieces and
two points I mean it's not completely
ridiculous sacrifice very difficult for
for whites to make any headway here
threatening Knight f3 okay this is what
I'm not sure yeah do I want to trade
that maybe I want I don't know
[ __ ] behind on the clock so want to be
quick here
very difficult to imagine how wide isn't
going to open up the position here the
only real way to do it is with
sacrifices do I go f6 or not let's do
that well that covered
yeah the the issue is it's not to to get
to get forward here I think for for
drawing I just have to stay and do
nothing but can I do something is the
question maybe d5 it's it's a bit
ambitious but well it's just the Blitz
game so maybe here and 96 Jeff form he
will hit her he will definitely give up
one of his rooks for for one of the
nights so cover f6 and I know 96 f4 is
coming he I am
yeah you will sacrifice but
no I'm not sure about this I still get
rookie 5 and so on
rookie 5 rookie 6 my looks and night are
quite quite strong I mean I D does not
need to sacrifice but the Knights are
always very irritating I'm not
threatening much really I can just take
H fire [ __ ] I don't know
yes we decided to sacrifice at the end
and my idea is to double on the e-file
and try to I know I have look here it's
not it looks quite good
Queen g3 mm-hmm I can check him now here
I don't know
Jack King f1 night h3 is just to win I
think so he has to go to the H file
check
I'm warning kingi for don't tell me that
this is not losing for white he's
playing that anyway puts himself in kind
of a self media but maybe there is no
win would be kind of unfair but it could
be okay let's try that for rookie form
there no window
maybe there isn't with f5 he almost has
no squares check check check
I don't see a win and maybe this one for
f5 I only have 20 seconds
jack-jack 4h form made almost Group III
was made already I know I know and now I
only have 20 seconds left
look f5 was also checkmate how blind am
I here but then he doesn't have a check
there maybe he cannot prevent the mate
ah
I have rook f3 and Luke f5 mate King
cannot move no no no were the clear
heads this is Major
he came up prevented a very silly Ruby
five I can made him in two ways but he
has also not ecigs mate so Luca three
made rook at five made 96 matey cannot
check main event oh wow what a what a
ride
yeah and it's um I think that you can do
that Queen sacrifice I have so strong
pieces unless he's getting to open open
the position quickly I think this is a
very valid way to play yeah and I can
also give it for look and and peace here
with takes here or with sorry I can also
take here but I wasn't really sure here
in this case in this case I wasn't sure
about about my my structure I'm left
with two silly looking pieces I think in
this in this case my pieces look better
the question is if he can really open it
up quickly I mean he move like d4 here
the question if is if this is this is
really relative and does this kind of
thing yeah then he will enter so this is
maybe the way to refute my idea I was
thinking this move but he s see three
young pointed out by the engine yeah
this is not looking good
he has to do something like that Queen
III is right he has to open the position
quickly on the Queen side and after
after that it's over with an advantage I
mean you cannot trust the compare the
computer gives one point for white but
that's simply not true it's it's a
computer is just counting stuff IAM and
the problem is that in this structure
white has no way to to penetrate to my
position I mean I cannot do much myself
but it's just completely okay a computer
has stopped for just giving 0.9 yeah
maybe that's that's not too far off I
mean I think it's equal actually but why
doesn't have a decisive advantage or
something like that it's very difficult
to to do something here against my
structure yeah I think he also should
just take it with the bishop this is
something that he I should take the
chance to and get rid of one of the
Knights and here maybe he can try for
something the bishop is not so useful
here I mean the kid can go to his six
where it is nicely anchored I have many
setups that have fortress kind of
character and well here I'm starting to
play for window I could have one
actually with f5 hmm yeah that's very
strong really that's really strong
threading f4 he has to take it and now
Knight takes Bishop takes rook takes
four f3 Knight f3 this is just a
fantastic position
okay now I didn't didn't think of I was
only thinking in terms of the structure
I did not think dynamically which was a
which was just a bad way of thinking I
wasn't thinking about f-5e at all I was
thinking okay let's trade the bishops
and then set up with this formation
which is completely safe for me and I
wanted to to adduce them to put a safe
position up first and then think what to
do and I could have played an f5 ok d5 I
got tempted to do something because
we're white cannot do anything so let's
let's try yeah yeah that's a tough
decision he took a long while until
until he took it the problem with the
move is that it also opens up the e-file
and I don't really know if I'm
threatening much here maybe he can just
yeah let them stay on the board but you
always feel very irritated by your
little bit those by those nights near
the king yeah yeah here black is better
the question is just how much his king
is very insecure computer gives 96 with
an advantage yeah this also dr.
attention oh man eyes many tactical
shots in this game
wha-wha-wha yeah well I tend to do that
anyway but early-morning games 94 and
white resigns okay Jack Jack yeah rook
h5 wins the honey and rookie III is also
winning leading to checkmate
probably yeah that in fact also wins but
it's not as good of course
and now g6 is a force checkmate so yeah
at least that I found with f5 mate he
cannot prevent it by a king king g7 is
actually also quite
good just keeping everything as it is
and threatened threatened dismayed funny
but this should work he can only play we
have six to prolong things and here jack
yeah I should just give the maid of
course yeah look every male late or this
may I played this which is silly but he
cannot prevent the next move media his
there's too many made threats so I
played a really silly way here but this
is still still a maid yeah so it was a
fun game I hope and think you enjoyed
watching it
Thanks